[Music]
hey what's up my name's samuel leeds i'm
sat here with lee and joe they have got
over 150 properties in their portfolio
with a portfolio worth over 20 million
pounds and in this interview they're
gonna be talking exactly how they've
built up such a humongous property
portfolio and how you can do the same
thing too so hey guys thank you so much
for coming to my house samuel thank you
very much for the invite really
appreciate it that's really interesting
is most in my experience most rich
people and you might not consider
yourselves rich but most people would
consider
normal people would consider you as rich
with such a massive portfolio
most rich people hide away and they
don't come on youtube they don't talk
about how much they're earning how they
did it so my first question is what made
you guys agree to sit down in my house
with the cameras on and openly share
about how you've done it
well first of all we just love your
videos and the inspiration
um especially you've given my son so
it's been amazing hasn't it yeah
absolutely
so uh he's managed to buy his first
property uh at age 16 down to coming on
the crash course that is ridiculous
absolutely crazy i can't wait to unravel
how that happened and what he did um
your backgrounds then you're both uh
hairdressers and that's that's your sort
of industry
how did this all start i mean you bought
your first property before i was even
born which makes me feel extremely young
um 32 years ago is that correct 32 years
ago yeah you just drilled into me you've
got to buy your house got to buy your
house yeah and
so i bought the first one when it was 21
then i paid 44 000 for it within six
months the value went down to about 36
000. interesting interesting yeah so
then i carried on saving and i wanted to
buy another property all the banks and
everything we said no bad investment i
said well the price has gone down
obviously they're on sale now this is a
good time to buy
so went round to every single bank this
is pre-buy to let so had to go along
have a business plan and i couldn't find
anyone to lend me the money
uh read a book and said you don't know
how close you are to success if you give
up so i thought i'm not going to give up
so i thought the last place i'm going to
try was my existing bank who wouldn't
give me an overdraft for a hundred pound
so i thought i'll try them saw the bank
manager um he looked at me and said
where you got the money from the deposit
as well i've saved it
and
he said right we're going to give you a
chance so we had to go with profit and
loft uh forecast and he lent me the
money to buy the the second property
then so that was just uh straightforward
buy it right buy it
out sit on it and then another time as
well like looking back if we if we could
look back if we could if we could look
fast forward into the future i mean in
the 90s property prices
absolutely soared um all through the 90s
and like i mean you can look back in the
last even even the last 50 60 70 years
every 10 years property prices have
basically doubled every 10 years and
everyone thinks yeah but that's not
going to happen in the next 10 and but
they were saying that when i started in
2008.
it's finished now the boom has finished
but actually the houses that i bought in
2009 2010 have now doubled in value so
there's just something about property
history repeats itself yeah all the time
so and also you're still
both aggressively investing today and
your strategies have changed you're
doing more creative things now a lot
more creative now with the knowledge and
the experience that we've gleaned over
the years everything's a lot different
now so when you guys met then joe um lee
was already a property investor on a
small time he had about eight properties
yeah he had eight so what what what how
where did you find out and how did you
it was a couple of months in so you kept
it quiet at first yeah
again rich people hiding away
yeah yeah i think yeah i think you
didn't wanna you didn't want a
girlfriend that was just after you
because you had eight houses maybe so he
kept it quiet we were both in the same
hairdressing industry and
yeah so in fact
i think uh it was when i was always
around the town yeah we said about
viewing properties you've got to view
the most properties used to see me and i
was always running around to estate
agents literally running pre-internet so
literally i'd run from a state agency to
a state
running between those states why are you
running everywhere so i'm actually
running to the estate agents trying to
get all the viewings in
wow yeah it's true and also joe you said
that you know why you'll be at the salon
he'd be getting paid from his tenants
and those like the paint yes they
weren't i think this surely isn't all
coming from hairdressing what's going on
yeah i was a little bit suspicious at
first
thinking
you know where is all this cash coming
from every day
honestly yeah absolutely yeah
i knew i knew he was an honest guy but
yeah obviously that's where it was
coming from and i didn't know that at
the time but yeah another thing is this
i know that when you started when you
were building your portfolio you would
live massively below your means and you
know work really hard save every penny
live massively below your means and then
invest which is quite an old cool
old school kind of strategy which i
think you've changed your mind a little
bit since then but just talk to me about
how your philosophy maybe has changed as
a as an investor from in the 90s or
early 2000s to now in 2021
well i think back then knew
nothing else apart from you had to save
a deposit buy the next house save the
deposit now with all the different
strategy lease options rent to rent etc
i didn't know any of that back then yeah
so now obviously the strategies have all
changed so what did you think when you
guys came to my property investors crash
course because i remember being really
surprised because we do have people at
the property university's crash course
that are successful we have people that
have got you know four or five houses
and they're looking to scale up but a
lot of people that come to the property
investors crash course beginners just
starting out so i was going around
asking people and it was a virtual crash
course as well so i was calling people
out on the screen you know what are you
here to learn you know where are you
starting from and i was asking everybody
where they were from what their
backgrounds were
and i remember seeing you and you were
there at the at the crash course and i
said you know right what are you here
tonight and you came across really
humble and said i'm here to learn about
this this this i'm here to network i
need to be inspired i'm here to get and
i said great and are you in property at
the moment and you said yes i said great
how long have you been in property you
said 32 years and i thought maybe you
owned a couple of properties and you've
owned them for years so have you got a
decent portfolio yeah 150 houses i was
like wow you know
you should be running the course what's
happening so firstly what was it that
made you book on and and then secondly
what was your experience
experience was fantastic the enthusiasm
the inspiration you give everyone is
amazing
but you can always learn something it
doesn't matter how small it is but that
could be something that could change
something when you're out in business
you think ah there's something else i
could do here maybe that strategy won't
work but this will yeah we've always um
right from the beginning haven't we
always attended everything we could
possibly attend networked wherever we
could
um learn something wherever we can so
you know as soon as we realized that you
were on
um doing virtual crash courses when we
were in lockdown we were like right
let's let's attend yeah so that's yeah i
think we've been on three now yeah we
were at the physical crash course last
week last week yeah fantastic again made
some good contacts there as well yeah
amazing amazing well it's great it's
really good for me as well it's nice
confirmation to hear uh you know other
property investors they're very
successful coming in and saying that the
content's great and it works um so
that's fabulous so talk to me a little
bit i'm going to come on to you soon
later and what he's done but you vanilla
buy to let people understand it makes
sense
putting money into bricks and mortar the
bricks and mortar is going to hold its
value you're also getting rent talk
about some of the creative strategies
that you've done i know now you're doing
service accommodation you've done um
you've done lease option agreements
you've done some incredible deals and uh
you were just telling me for instance
about the deal that you did in uh talk
talking yeah um so that's interesting
because that's a joint venture as well
right um that's permitted development so
bought that at auction so there's lots
of different things all in that one deal
really so talk me through the deal let's
hear because there's a lot of lessons in
there so obviously constantly thinking
about property moment we wake up first
thing we do is probably jump on right
move all the estate agents having to
look at that that's all we ever talk
about
so we're searching found this property
talkies getting redeveloped at the
moment saw this property coming up to
auction it was 200 000 did some research
on it previous person had paid about
half a million for it
so i thought it was a bit steep so went
to auction didn't sell went back to
auction for a second time still didn't
sell third time went back to auction
didn't sell now they've reduced the
reserve to 150 000. now it starts to
look a bit more interesting and this is
in torquay
what is this
talkies uh
i think it's just been renowned for the
best seaside resort in britain now
during lockdown sorry but yeah but
what's the property is it like it's uh
it's a commercial property with offices
above so why do you think in a boom
which we've been in for the last 18
months this property wasn't selling at
auction why did it continually fail
i think possibly because it's a bit
harder to get finance on the commercial
property yeah
perhaps other people didn't see the
angle that we saw on it against
experience
on this particular property the ground
floor rates payable were around about 30
000 a year so if it's empty so suddenly
you've got this property that's draining
you by 30 000 a year and commercial
properties are valued based on their
rent based on their rent and if there's
no rent then the commercial property is
going to be very difficult to finance
the landlords lost his tenant who was
paying 37 000 a year at the time yeah so
we knew that if we reduced the space on
the commercial element um we can get the
rates exempt then so so what do you say
you presumably pre-auction right call
the eight call the no this is post
auction so this is post auction so it
keeps going back on so is it pretty or
is it private so it's post auction now
reserve
you can buy it for 150. so we said we're
gonna buy it blind at 140. so the
auctioneer said no reserves 150. we're
sticking at that so i said well we
haven't seen it i'm in portugal at the
time so later on he said do you want to
buy it i said well no we don't want to
buy it at the 150. he said we'll do a
viewing business partner went along
viewed the property he had a look did a
zoom call with him
he said yeah it's a good buy he's not
super excited so i said right we'll
offer 125 now so we went back to the
auctioneer offered 125. he said well
they wouldn't accept 140 they're not
going to accept 125. i said well we've
seen it now we've seen a bit of damp
this that and the other and eventually
came back and said right they're going
to take the 125 so we took it at the
125. fantastic so 125 you've got this
commercial property when was this last
year this was about last year yeah it's
june just just post lock down actually
yeah just post lock down post lock down
while everyone else is worrying about
lock down you're out so we're out
can you get this discount so we've got
got this property now
we split it yeah into two separate units
now so now we're rates exempt so we
haven't got pay rates on it so suddenly
it's not costing us anything to have
this property yep
we've advertised it we've reduced the
rent massively
we can't afford to now we've only paid
125 000 we get renting of 15 000 a year
from the shop now so suddenly it's all
paying for itself looking lovely and
then we've applied for permitted
development for the upper floors to
convert into two flats
so
that's going to cost us around about a
hundred thousand and value is going to
be about 450. so bought it for one two
five one two five gonna have to spend
about a hundred hundred thousand on it
thousands all in about two two five two
two five with an end value of 400 grams
for 400 450
we're getting 15 000 for the shop and
for each of the flats on service
accommodation should get around about 15
000 each for them so there we go
still doing deals today the best kind of
deals as well like basically that's a
it's a brr this is serviced
accommodation joint venture it's a joint
housing how did you join ventura who's
the job mitch partner uh i won't name
him but he's cash rich
doesn't want to get involved in uh
dealing with tenants builders or
anything else like that he's putting the
money in he's put he's put some of the
money in we've gone 50 50. yeah
on it question then question for you
actually joe
why when you have got lots of houses and
you're doing well financially why would
you find a joint venture partner to put
the money in why would you not just
finance everything yourself
because um
the money our pot of money then that
we're then reinvesting gets spread
further if you're doing joint ventures
and this is a guy that we've been
working with for years anyway so you
know he gets a good return he's happy
um so yeah so do you think in order to
scale big like you guys have done 20
million pound portfolio just scale big
work starting as hairdressers you didn't
receive inheritance money when you got
started
pets self-made self-made
so to be able to get a 20 million pound
property portfolio with 150 properties
or so
do you think that to do that really you
need to be leveraging other people's
money the bank's money bringing in joint
ventures yeah you have to that's
that's why it was slow at the start
because i wasn't doing that yeah
and that's a massive lesson and that's i
mean and that's what we teach right it's
like you don't have to have lots of
money to start with you need to be able
to just pull in other people's money now
your son who's 16
which we i'd love to talk about what he
did and how he did it but firstly why
did you send him on the crash course and
send him to may when you could have just
told him yourself
well he usually explained that 17 17. no
he's 17 now yeah 17 now but he was 16
when he came to the crash course yeah
last year so what did you send him what
are you just telling yourself because
you've got 150 oh my god he's heard us
he's grown up listening to us like there
must be so much information in his brain
anyway that he doesn't even realize he's
there because he's absorbed it over the
years but
um
i think he's done he stumbled across
samuel i think on his own didn't he yeah
yeah he stumbled across you and then he
just started talking to us about you and
we said oh yeah we we've heard of samuel
lee we know who you mean and it just
came about that way i think didn't it
but it's that inspiration your energy
was so infectious yeah yeah do you think
sometimes as well hearing the same thing
but with a different voice and something
definitely having that third party
just made all the difference yeah yeah
so okay so he comes to the crash course
aged 16 at the time now he's 17 and
presumably he would have loved to hand
out from his parents and he that would
have been great i mean most who wouldn't
but you refused to go down that route
and you said we're actually not going to
give you a penny but we will teach you
we'll give you the experience we'll send
you off on a crash course but you need
to get the money in the investor
yourself is that correct that's correct
yeah
what happened so
i said we know certain people with money
you can have to explain it what you're
doing and what this money's for and how
you're going to secure it we'll explain
everything to you but it's going to be
your property deal so he's going to have
to pitch private investors himself
and you're not going to give him any
money we're we're helping him we're
standing in by the by by the side and
and who found the deal
um
which i think i think it was a joint
thing we were doing looking together we
were looking together we were looking
together and then he had to pick it and
then he had to find out and
you'd give him you'd give him your
opinion right so he'll be able to say
look i'm looking at this what do you
think and you you'd be like your course
you said the sign and said why have you
picked this and then you would explain
why you picked that i said well i think
that works what are the figures and he's
working out the figures and we've got
the spreadsheets and i said yeah yeah i
think it's a great thing to be able to
do though what an amazing
thing to be able to and i i mean i i
can't wait until my son's 16. i was
gonna say 18b enough to be 18. but but
until i can sort of sit with him and go
right i'm not going to give you any
money but i'll help you i mean what the
best gift you can give your kids i've
got three kids now is not your money but
it's your personal development and your
education and you've been your knowledge
yeah but that experience has been
invaluable he's learning about so much
about epcs the tenancies everything
you guys look at it it looks good what
the figures i paid 36 000 for it wow
where is it it's in durham okay i've got
houses in durham as well house said 36
house man just is this something like
open market or no it was uh believe it a
buy it now auction okay so it's a bit
like ebay
right so that's it you commit yourself
and you buy it now cool 36 grand he
finds the house
and then he finds an investor
and he pitches them on it and what
happened next what's the deal so he said
he'll be his own company so he's got his
own limited company so he's put it into
that can you own can you have a company
when you're 16 17. yeah uh so he's got
i'm a director of the company yeah um so
he's the 100 shareholder as well okay so
okay so you can set up a company as a
kid whereby you are 100 shareholder yeah
but you need an adult to be a director
um
he can be a director as well yeah
i didn't even know that yeah so he can
be a director as well and the company
has bought the property the company's
bought the property and he set up a bank
account as well so he's got his bank
account
so how did the pitch go when he pitched
it to this investor
i think because obviously
he's got the security me being our
director as well yeah um and he's got
first charge over the property
and is the investor getting fixed return
or was it he's going to fix
nice he was getting zero points
something in a nicer yeah um so it was a
no-brainer for him yeah that's awesome
he must be really proud of himself and
you guys must be really proud of him joe
yeah he's very proud of him i have to
say in lockdown like all he wanted to do
was was learn and he was trying to pin
you down to training wasn't he every
single day because you were in lockdown
in portugal and we were in england
so we did it virtually dad dad we need
to we need to face time we need an
hour's training
all through the different properties and
everything so you were like his mentor
basically he was yeah
that's absolutely so we paid 36 000 he's
just increased the rent from
433 to 450.
incredible
so your son has got his own house age 16
no money down deal and it's basically
against the same stuff that we teach
right it's just use other people's money
exactly adventures here's how you
structure it learn to find deals if you
find the right deals the money will come
there's so much money out there you've
just got to find it yeah so okay
um there's a lot of people watching this
that might be a little bit like your son
in terms of they haven't got money
they're wanting to get started they've
got the same fire that your son's got uh
rocco right yeah same passion saying
fire but they're thinking i wish i had
parents that could help me because
people can be thinking right even though
you didn't give him any money i wish i
had parents that could mentor me and
would send me off on samuel lee's crash
course and stuff i mean a lot of most
people's parents are like don't go to
these courses you just focus on getting
a job so what advice
with the time that we've got right now
would you give to my viewers
how how can they do this
um
to get around people that can teach them
and help them yeah networking
um yeah just just don't give up keep
going and all the nay says just keep
going keep going keep going and never
stop because you don't know how close
you are to success if you give up yeah
the moment you give up you failed
you've got to keep going not giving up
it's important but most people don't
even get started
you've got to make the start
the journey of a thousand steps starts
with one step but a lot don't do that
yeah a lot just think about it think
about it think about it and they don't
even make that step but yeah getting
started not giving up getting around the
right people yeah good advice and that
that's still important for us
you know all these years later we still
need to be around the right people
all the time
yeah yeah regularly you need that
injection of positivity and people you
can you can bounce ideas off of and you
just learn so much even after all these
years don't you definitely yeah i mean
just watching you were always motivated
it inspires us even now 32 years later
that in energy is so infectious
i think it's really important who you're
around is who you become and
i think it's super important some of the
strategies as well i mean um lease
option agreements man simple it's not
difficult if they taught this in school
which we'll get onto yeah it's not
difficult it's not complicated but you
don't necessarily need to
work super super super hard on a job for
40 years to save enough deposit to buy a
house you can use things like these
option agreements you guys um
did a very juicy lease option agreement
um talk me through the the numbers and
how that worked um
well the numbers basically it was a
property developer he wanted to sell
this property he was struggling to sell
it because there was no kitchen there
was no bathroom so effectively he
couldn't sell it to anyone more
mortgageable right so
but some people might say
you need a mortgage to buy unless you've
got cash unless you've got cash yeah but
you managed to secure it with no other
cash so
he was just i don't want to see the
property fed up with that yeah so i said
well
we'll pay a lease option fee each month
for the property
and we'll have the option for two years
so anytime in that two years we'll
exercise the option to buy it yeah 225.
he said fine that's it's off my hands
you've got to ensure you look after it
you do whatever you want to the place so
you retail by how much per month i think
it was about 800 a month so you
basically said
you you basically own it look mr owner
you want two to five yep you can't sell
it yeah it's not mortgageable
no one wants to buy in the state it's in
i'll buy it for two to five but let me
fix it up first that's it exactly
you secured an option agreement which is
a very legit uh
you know by
being motivated by dissatisfaction so we
moved into the property i don't think he
was too pleased about it but i was not
pleased no so we moved in the property
started work on it got all the kitchens
in bathroom et cetera got it
mortgageable and a few years later we
then sold it okay so
the great thing about you living there
as well is you have to pay rent to live
anyway don't you exactly quit a month is
quite standard rent so you were paying
japan a month you fixed it up you got it
mortgageable how much did you spend
fixing it up uh about 150 000 right and
did you use your own money or did you
get development finance no use my own
money used your own money fair enough
but if you didn't have your own money
yeah guess what it was it was just over
the period of time so yeah so you spent
150 on it so in total that's two to five
plus 150 so you're talking about three
seven five three seven five um
and but how much did you sell it for
five seven five five seven five again
man two hundred thousand pounds clean
profit it was our principal residence as
well it was what our principal residence
and you live there yeah does that mean
you didn't pay any capital against that
yeah
dude man guys that's incredible so
these skills and these tricks and these
tips around property what would you say
if for someone starting out best
strategy to start because i think a lot
of people are confused they're like
lease option agreement brr service
departments in torquay auctions vanilla
by chile and they've got all these
different strategies going around i mean
what what would you say best advice get
started i think some people have just
got a scattergun approach they're trying
to do everything yeah just gotta focus
on what i was just gonna say that focus
on one to start with
yeah one and just do that depending on
people's circumstances learn the skills
for that you've got deposits and stuff
like that and you've got money perhaps
do the vrr yeah you haven't got that
perhaps do rent to rent yeah what do you
think about all these people that are
now getting into property and doing i
mean you see you've been to three crash
courses now you see on samuel 365
you can see all this these people
winners on the ones that are doing
property um what do you think about that
it's fantastic it's amazing
but do you not think that some some
investors would like more about you guys
is the fact that when you see me helping
hello's people get into property some
people would think don't tell them
everything because they'd want to keep
all the properties for themselves even
people that i've helped start from
nothing
become successful they don't want to
come on winners on a wednesday because
they're like i don't want people
stealing the ideas and i'm like a year
ago you were broke and i've helped you
and you've become successful and now you
don't want to come on windows on
wednesday because you're people stealing
the ideas imagine if i'd have had that
actually before 12 months ago i mean
with you guys you've been in the game
for 32 years but off a 20 million pound
portfolio what what why is it that you
love seeing other people win so much
it's just so exciting just seeing the
smile on someone's face that excitement
it's just amazing it takes you back to
like the early days as well doesn't it
so you know when we were getting started
and stuff yeah we met a young man
yesterday he was at um a property
conference and he's just starting out
rent to rent
and just seeing the enthusiasm yeah i
think it's lovely it's just amazing yeah
because i remember being back there
trying to start out asking questions and
people are closed book and you're
thinking well how did they do it how did
they get that and they just weren't
willing to share that information a lot
of people aren't yeah just get around
people get around people doing it that's
that's probably what i would say just
get around people out doing it and just
just copy what they're doing you know
just learn from them absorb everything
and a lot of people well i think will
find excuses as to why it's hard for
them they'll say oh it's all right for
you or you got lucky or you but i think
you know you guys started with nothing
and you know you're both working as
hairdressers um
ultimately that you can either find
excuses as to why you can't do something
or you can just dig deep into what the
reason is why you need to do this and
you know it's great to be inspired by
other people and that's another thing
when you see other people doing it it's
like actually there's no reason it kind
of robs you of an excuse so people right
now are going to be watching your story
hearing how you started nothing that can
either go holy moly if they can do it i
can they'll be inspired or they'll say
oh well and they'll try and find a
reason or an excuse or justification um
have you guys had like haters or people
trying to bring you down or come up with
excuses as to why you've done it and
they can't have you had to deal with
that yeah yeah
um
it's sometimes it's a bit difficult um
well you name one
i don't well to be honest i don't i
don't yeah i don't spend much time
thinking about that if you know if
people are going to be negative then
move on
right move on
don't waste my energy or worry about it
you hear it yeah but you don't want to
you get a thicker skin yeah you get a
thicker skin over the years
one of the questions you guys asked me
you told me you wanted to me to write a
book on dealing with haters and you said
that would be the first book you agreed
why did you say that
it's sometimes it's difficult you know
you're running this business and it is a
business so that's what they have to
understand we're running a business
we're trying to do it ethically
ethically and profitably yeah yeah
what do you think joe
yeah no that that yeah
do you think the media sometimes as well
i think this even when you watch tv
shows you know the the rich guys are
always the bad guys yeah the media don't
like landlords this is there's this kind
of idea that landlords are greedy people
and you know try and squeeze the maximum
rent out of the tax but i got a lot of
stick over my book by low rent high
because it's like
buy low brent high he's trying to
squeeze the rent but he's like no what
i'm talking about is buy low yeah by
finding someone that's got a property
that they're motivated to sell it and
i'm helping them out you are yeah rent
it high by changing the use and renting
out
just breaking it up room by room
providing luxury affordable
accommodation
when you get paid well it's because
you're adding value yeah it's because
you're helping people yeah greedy
landlords almost don't exist because if
you're a greedy landlord and you try and
put the rent really high you're gonna
have an empty house
if you're a greedy landlord and you
don't fix things you're gonna have bad
tenants you're gonna end up damaging
your own property the best way to be i
mean i'm a capitalist right i believe in
compassionate capitalism and i think the
best way to get wealthy in business is
to help people
add value and as landlords i mean you've
got 150 properties and you know a lot of
tenants i mean what do you think about
that oh definitely um it's all about
helping people and
like with service accommodation it's
lovely seeing people going into the
property having a wonderful holiday
seeing all the feedback they've had an
amazing time so we love seeing that as
well when did you guys start doing
service accommodation in this country
when did you start
in this country yes um
when uh
when we moved out of film house yeah it
was probably about 2008. yeah okay so
you've been in a long time 2008. a very
long time and that's a that's a large
property that accommodated 18 at the
time
service accommodation became a big thing
when i started teaching it
right
when the tax changes came in yeah
because when section 24 was announced
and they started phasing that in
everybody firstly is thinking hang on a
minute if i'm just gonna rent my
property out the normal way and i'm
getting taxed unless i can change my
property to a company i'm going to get
clobbered with tax yeah i need to get
some higher rent i need to get so that's
that's the first reason but secondly
with service accommodation section 24
tax doesn't apply
so
more and more people now are buying
properties to rent out um on short term
lets what are
the pros and cons would you say to
service accommodation via just putting a
long term letting it
the property's always constantly looked
after you checking it every week making
sure any maintenance is always dealt
with straight away so
sometimes a tenant won't even tell you
about a maintenance issue suddenly you
say well couldn't you've told me about
the seal around the bath going or
something like that you know and he's
been left for months so you're
constantly checking the property yeah
which is always good
um do you know what about that point
it's it's funny you say it's ironic
because a lot of people
don't want to get into service
accommodation because they're worried oh
the tenants might damage it or the
guests might have parties but actually i
found the same thing in service
they're pristine yeah you have to keep
them pristine it's like your property is
actually going to hold its value better
it's fantastic for the consumer as well
because when we started out
i think in our area there was only what
10 properties
available yeah and that's 2008 and now
how many is there the hundreds hundreds
of properties now so it's good for the
consumer because the competition's so
much higher the standards are getting
higher and higher and higher and to stay
up on top yeah you've got to keep your
standards way up there yeah
tax benefits are really good as well tax
benefits cash flow
and cash flow is fantastic especially
now with a staycation boom that we've
got oh man return is the biggest biggest
bonus i think yeah absolutely massive so
in terms of your portfolio you've got a
lot of properties yeah and as you know
you know about my story and what i'm
doing i've sold off quite a lot of my
little properties and i'm moved on to
doing development and bigger deals
what's your focus what's your plan are
you planning on just continuing to buy
more houses are you moving to do bigger
deals development what's your plan for
the future we're looking at doing a bit
more development um because we've been
away for six years in portugal so we've
now come back because our son and
daughter starting to get interested in
the property business so we're looking
at doing different things just depends i
mean we've just bought um a deal what
was it 12 months ago it was a pub and a
cottage
and it's interesting because it was on
right move but it was on a with a
commercial agent
but the cottage should have been with a
residential agent so they were selling
it on a commercial basis and it was way
undervalued wow uh that particular one
we paid 80 000 for the pub 141
000 for the house
uh we've spent about five thousand on
the house just had it revalued at 350.
nice and the pub itself we're now
applying for planning permission to turn
into two flats fantastic
in terms of lifestyle how how has life
changed from when you guys first met you
were working in a salon your
hairdressers um what's an average day
look like now what does what does life
look like has life changed
well we just got back from six years in
portugal and life's been pretty
incredible over there yeah um we were uh
we were on a um portugal has a scheme
called the non-habitual residency which
has massive bonuses for for landlords if
they're wanting to sell properties did
you want to speak a bit more about that
so that was
uh one aspect of our life we wanted to
reduce some of the portfolio get some of
the
lesser performing properties out of the
portfolio yeah and mitigate their cgt
by becoming a non-resident we're allowed
to do that right so we moved away but at
the same time we were still buying
properties in england in england
remotely so we ran everything
so we lived there for six years and we
ran everything in england remotely
didn't we so i think most of the
properties we've bought are all remote
yeah that's pretty fantastic yeah the
fact that you've managed to do it so
that it's so systemized
because again a lot of people think that
to be a landlord you have to buy a
property close to your house now you
know i disagree with that yeah well
we've got properties from penzance to
sunderland
and obviously properties in spain
portugal how do you how do you set up
the management system so well
it's it's a slow process you meet good
contacts and everything else like that
and if that contact's not performing
well then you find one that is so we've
got contact now in uh sunderland they
source the properties for us they manage
all the refurbishments and everything
then we have a zoom meeting with them
we've got the technology now yeah we've
got the software there's no reason not
to so it's just about power teaming
really power and having that confidence
you see the experience you get the
confidence of doing this yeah at first
it may seem a little bit nerve-wracking
buying a property you've not actually
physically gone in yeah
how many hours a week would you say
you know in that six years living in
portugal how many hours a week were you
guys working combined with relaxing
we
well we tried to we generally worked in
the mornings we tried to knock off
around
lunchtime yeah and go out and have lunch
and
go out on a boat
yeah so mornings were well it's normally
start around about six o'clock in the
morning and then finish
about lunch time he's an early riser
i can sit there check all the accounts
do everything yeah and then any
maintenance i can just instruct everyone
was that work do you think that if you
really wanted to if you really wanted to
could you systemize it completely so
that you weren't working at all oh
definitely right but i like keeping my
finger on the pulse seeing what's going
on are you still growing the business
and still growing the business
and a lot of the work is finding new
deals overseeing new deals that's the
exciting part that's what i actually
like
you're actively choosing to continue to
grow but if you wanted to you could just
literally walk away from it so passive
income
um i hear people saying oh passive
income it's just it's a myth you can't
really create passive income um what do
you guys think been in the game 32 years
i think passive income i mean it depends
even if you've got stocks and shares is
it totally passive sometimes you want to
manage your portfolio
readjust your portfolio so it's not
totally passive i mean unless you get
your money just put it in a bank account
you want to look after your portfolio
you want to see what's going on with
your properties
some may not be performing too well or
the capital growth's gone up so much the
rent's not matching the capital growth
so you want to sell it yeah perhaps buy
two others so you still want to monitor
you keep an eye on it you've got to keep
an eye on it yeah yeah i think so i
think why would anyone work why would
anyone trade their time for money you
know we can't understand that that
philosophy you know
that's normal though yeah i know yeah
that's just you that's just what we're
told we've all done it when we were
younger
but poverty is the fantastic thing you
can actually scale it and you can scale
it as quickly or slowly as you want to
and while you're talking about like
overseeing it managing it checking the
numbers checking the finances i mean
that that's the definition of passive
income is um money with little to no
work so yeah it's not to say yo i'm
gonna buy a few properties and i'm never
gonna you want to look at it you want to
see what's going on
but i think it's just about really what
i'm talking about is the idea of being
able to replace your income so you don't
need to have a job
which i think is very achievable in fact
to make two three grand a month
in property income when you understand
about rent to rent when you understand
about the lease option agreements when
you understand about joint ventures it's
not that difficult in my opinion
no it's not difficult
but you've got to be committed and
you've got to do the work you've got to
be committed and do the work to get a
job and go to university if we were
taught like you're teaching your kids
about property about passive income
about being financially literate if we
were taught that imagine what would
happen if that was taught in schools
yeah incredible i wish i had the
knowledge i have now back when i started
as i said
i'm saving the deposits i didn't know
about rent to rent i met uh
someone yesterday at a property
conference yeah yeah you mentioned a
good good friend of mine and i said
how's things going he said oh yeah yeah
really good i said what are you up to he
said oh i've got about was it 120
places he's still got 120 places that i
said oh that's really good if you bought
himself no all rent to rent right yeah
amazing i said are you doing well he
said yeah he said yeah i'm making
tens of thousands a month yeah from the
rent
he said donna buy i said always i'd tell
the reasons why he said well because i'm
doing rent to rent section 24 doesn't
affect me right so he said because i'm
actually renting them
he said i can claim that as a 100
percent
yeah of course but i said i never even
thought about that yeah that's the thing
to make two three grand a month it's not
that difficult of course it's gonna take
some hard work of course you have to
roll your sleeve
definitely you have to muck in and you
have to put a lot of heaven to it um you
as well
um also like myself have a have a a
passion to see kids financially educated
and you know about what the works that
we're doing and the foundation within
the schools across the united states
incredible um
you had a little try at one point
too well before we got kicked out what
happened
i went to my son's school and
you're meant to give a talk about your
job
and i my opening line was i haven't got
a job
[Laughter]
so as explained what i did and i think
the teacher was pretty horrified i said
you know i was sort of dismissing
not so much school but the idea you just
don't have to leave school to get a job
yeah there is another alternative have a
business
and uh work for yourself yeah
what would be your if you were to i
would say regrets because regret's a
strong word but if you were to do
anything if you would do things
differently going back from the very
beginning what would you do differently
to what you did there
if i had the knowledge i have now yeah
i
could have scaled bigger
i would have bought more mm-hmm
definitely how have you done that though
because you were literally spending
everything yeah
yeah i didn't realize about the rent to
rent about the lease options about bur i
didn't realize any of those all i
realized i was focused on i have to save
the deposit to get another house that's
all i thought about i have to say though
it wasn't long into
growing the portfolio that you you did
change your strategy there slightly
because when i met you you had eight
houses
and i told you that i was saving a
deposit to buy a house didn't i oh
that's right to me this this was an
interesting story this is the story when
joe and i first met um
i think it was one of our second or
third dates or something yeah it was
quite a second date
and i went around to her place and she
had a little picture of this little
two-bedroom house well i had a five-year
plan actually with pictures yeah and i
was
up two down i just wanted to buy a small
house for me and my daughter i was a
single mom yeah just looking at this
picture in the world what's that's just
it's my dream house it's two bedroom
five year plan and i said five year plan
i said seems a
seems a long plan to get that what you
said was how is that going for you
saying that i was like
very well i'm not saying much already
let's look at properties today so we
went out that day and looked at some
show homes didn't we yeah and i bought a
house that day i went
he said
i said can't wait all this time five
years
plan i said you've got to do it today i
said let's work out the figures so we
saw this show home said well i've got
deposit i said well you got a credit
card i've worked out the figures the
payment on the credit card the payment
on the house i said i've worked
everything out i said
i'm not advising anyone to buy a house
with a credit card but i said all works
out i said if you can't afford it the
rent will pay for your credit card right
and the house and that's good debt so we
like i'm not advising you to buy the
house with a credit card but here's a
credit card
yeah what happens so that day you bought
it and brilliant parents went ballistic
no i was dreading telling them i was
like my god like i've just started
dating this guy and i'm going to go home
and say i've just bought a house today
on a credit card no money for the
deposit like but but the thing is that's
again that's the difference between good
debt and bad debt yeah if you're going
to buy a house on with a loan or a
credit card or whatever
if the rent is gonna pay the interest
and more
then that why would you not do that
exactly it was the best thing i ever did
and you still got that house today yeah
i was absolutely terrified at the time
but it was the best thing i ever did
yeah but then i read that book many
years ago uh russ whitney russ whitney
russ when he can't remember the name of
the book about russ whitney
and um
early on in our relationship you went
away for a week with the family
and i read this book and he said if all
the figures stack up
you should just go for the deal
and i
met two property investors and they had
some flats for sale but one block of six
and a block of five
all right
i said all the figures work out and i
actually borrowed all the deposits on
credit cards wow bought eleven flats
when you came back i said off you've
been busy i said well i bought 11 flats
and still got all the flats today just
off the back of reading a book reading a
book and then you just your mind just
completely changed it just changed that
psyche yeah and i said well yeah it
works it makes makes commercial sense
that's the thing i mean a lot of the
like which for me it was rich dad poor
dad no i read that later on yeah which
came later which was like a real woof
wow and um i mean for me being able to
have that same
me being able to
change the way that people think about
finances through our training company
through my videos and my books and stuff
it really does change people's lives
because when you understand when you're
financially literate and you understand
the difference between an asset and a
liability you understand the difference
between good debt and bad debt you
understand why not to save money and put
it in the bank why you don't need to
have a job and trade your time with
money forever until you're 67 when you
understand you don't have to do that
there is another way it is very very
liberating isn't it oh my god yeah it's
so refreshing yeah
in terms of properties as well like a
lot of people ask me they say why don't
you
own where you live because i'm a proud
renter at the moment
so do you rent where you live or do you
own where you live
we own where we live but we have
properties around it and
that basically services it
sorry how do you mean
so
i wanted a nice house yes and
either property we bought was basically
an estate so it's got a like a manor
house on it with all cottages but the
cottages service the main property oh so
you've got out buildings
not our buildings the houses so it's
like a small estate small oh wow small
country fair enough so what do you think
of my philosophy of renting where you
live
um
for me
i would want to buy but there again the
reason i want to buy is because i can
see an angle on it as well so yeah for
me i bought this lovely house but it had
all the out buildings if it didn't have
the out buildings i wouldn't have bought
it yeah yeah i think
your strategy for renting when you live
makes perfect sense really
but
again this is
it's not that dissimilar to what we did
whereas we wanted the properties to fund
the main house so yeah that's what we
did because people
can't get conquered over why property
investors that own lots of properties
would possibly want to rent where they
live well it's a bit like a car it's
like buying your car yeah would you want
to buy the car to spend fifty thousand
pound buying the car or use that fifty
thousand two third strategy and then
lease the car yeah yeah i think
leasing your lifestyle in my opinion
makes sense definitely yeah lease your
lifestyle and then use your money to
invest and then the money that you make
from the investments
live the lifestyle that you want
definitely um so if you're starting a
loan again from scratch
and you had 150 houses taken off yeah
yeah all your money everything taken
from you the only thing that you've got
is your knowledge
from what you've done
what are you gonna do
what am i gonna do
for me if i had not one penny yeah i
certainly wouldn't start trying to save
all over again
it's
too long and very painful yeah
yeah
that that takes years doing that and i
did that for about 10 years and then
realized that's going to be very slow
doing that that's where we started doing
the uh other strategies so definitely
start networking yeah in the right
groups with the right people and then
uh yesterday we met someone he's
starting out in rent to rent i then
introduced him to a letting agent
and he said well i actually do rent to
rent myself
i've got all these properties i
understand the strategy so put the two
together so this young man is now going
off to do rent to rent yeah and he can
he'll take the advice from the letting
agent he said because i'm going to
advise you right because if i advise you
wrong yeah then obviously it's going to
come back on me so so what would you do
would you do rent to rent me if i was
going to do it i'd probably do rent
right lease options rent to rent all
those strategies you can do with no
money packaging and selling deals get
some quick cash
package we've done a bit of that yeah
deals yeah we've done a few not many
yeah um done about three at the time i
didn't have the funds or didn't want to
do it whatever it was sell it on i knew
someone else that would fit their
criteria yeah so so you'd basically do
rental rents control properties maybe do
a bit of deal selling to get some
capital it wouldn't take long you'd find
great deals maybe bring joint venture
partners in on the deals
rebuild yeah absolutely it wouldn't take
long be much quicker the second time
around it would have second time around
it wouldn't take long
the knowledge is everything so you know
would you rather be stripped from all of
your knowledge or strip your houses from
you oh
tough time well obviously we need to
retain the knowledge
that's the most important thing i think
yeah i mean what a big statement
that's quite a big thing to say to say
you'd rather
you'd rather lose all your houses than
have your knowledge all completely
sucked out of you well if we didn't have
the knowledge we couldn't
possibly manage all the houses yeah
the most important factor i think yeah
oh i feel like that though yeah i'd
rather because if i lost all my houses i
know i'd go and get them again yeah
exactly i lost all my money i lost
everything i'd be able to rebuild it but
if i lost my knowledge then i'd be
useless and what i've got fine would
stay but i wouldn't be able to build i
wouldn't want to leave a legacy i want
them to train people exactly yeah
interesting though yeah been really
really interesting chatting with you
guys i hope it's been been an absolute
pleasure so much for having us and thank
you so much for inspiring everyone out
there it's fantastic well he's just real
welcome and i'm glad to see what your
song's done what would your advice be
you've been to three crash courses now
what were your advice to someone
starting out that's thinking about or
not even starting out maybe they've been
in properties like you guys have 32
years what would you say to someone
who's thinking about coming along as
experienced investors that have been
three times what would your advice be
what have you got to lose
literally what have you got to lose do
you go along
and you got everything to gain yeah
oh that's great yeah definitely well
guys thank you so so much for coming
down to my house thank you so much for
the invite really appreciate it great
seeing you and getting to know you guys
over the last year or so so there we
have it folks i hope you guys got a lot
of information from this there's so many
golden nuggets why don't you go ahead
smash the like button um after this
great interview with lee and joe also if
you've got questions comments thoughts
drop them in the comment box below i've
also interviewed honestly hundreds of
people and that have smack smashing it
in property so if you want more
inspiration you can check out an entire
playlist up here i've been doing this
for almost three years interviewing
people every single week don't forget to
subscribe up here and if you want to
join me in person at the property
investors crash course it's free i'll
leave a link in the description below
thanks so much peace out see you next
time